get our picture report here ken what you
got on luke weaver well luke's got a
fastball cutter change up he also throws
a curveball hasn't didn't throw any
curveballs in the first game against san
diego
amen 96 right by him one away
all fastballs to a dead fastball hitter
and blew the last one right by him at
96.
swinging into this there's the changeup
two reds batters and two strikeouts
here's a wind-up by weaver on the pitch
ground ball into the shift in the
outfield fielded by van meter and he
throws him out at first and an easy
inning recorded by luke weaver one two
three with a pair of strikeouts to open
the day jose de leon 28 year old right
hander that you know he liked luke weber
had a lot of runs given up in spring
training i think he had an earned run
average right around nine or close to it
but he struck out a lot of batters and
he's done that already so far this year
nine strikeouts five innings
check swing looked like he went
yes
and there's a k for jose de leon
here's the o2 that's up and in popped up
behind short suarez will go out he'll
make the catch in shallow left field for
out number two well he hadn't thrown one
yet i mean he's been all fastball so far
so far today there's a little bit of a
change up right there it'll get an easy
out
and get the shovel
and the flip on the infield so just a
single and a k for de leon
there's the heater at 94. he struck out
three the first four
[Applause]
oh that change up is looking good today
four strikeouts already for luke
this is driven hard to right castellanos
won't get there and it bounces over the
wall escobar is on fire it's a double to
start the second
you know score that a home run i'm not
sure they're getting together out there
there's some confusion among the umpires
i know you're gonna have to come back
here
he gave it a shot tried to steal second
and third david's got an rbi he's
hitting 250 as he steps to the plate
left-handed batter
that's in the gap
here comes escobar pavon smith makes it
one-nothing diamondbacks
oh he's rolling five strikeouts through
eight batters for luke weaver
[Applause]
david smith is there
three perfect for luke weaver with five
strikeouts he holds a one-nothing lead
down and away swinging to miss gathered
by stevenson put out complete
4k for de leon two on and one out now
for the freight train giants have an
early two-nothing lead on colorado
see you later david peralta goodbye
it's in the poll a splashdown for david
his first of the year
homer and it's four-nothing diamondbacks
[Applause]
oh yeah
i think that one actually did splash
down in the pool out there heads up kids
103 off the bat
boom
[Applause]
is fly to left to start the ending the
wind of the pitch and a ground ball to
second big up to van meter he's got it
and throws to first for the up
[Applause]
line right to ahmed
luke weaver has set down the first 12
he's faced and leads it four nothing and
here is walker where the base is loaded
oh for a big blow right now huh
signal given the pitch swing to miss he
struck him out with a slider down and
away big strikeout and the diamondbacks
leave him loaded without scoring in the
fourth and weaver 12 up 12 down five k's
three and two to suarez and a fly ball
hit to center la castro's there tim's
got it one out
like that right back
six strikeouts he's set down the first
14 cincinnati batteries
deright haven smith
luke weaver is perfect through five
and holds a four nothing lead
here's a windup by de leona the next one
swinging a shot to right center while
the run castiano's he'll have to track
that one down to the wall out there into
second base goes peralta with a stand up
double well looks like his bat's back
speaking of escobar he doubled and
scored in the second here he is
and the 2-0 pitch to him
swinging a drive to right
four games
and
four home runs for eduardo
and the diamondbacks lead at six to
nothing he has homer in four consecutive
games
the first diamondback to do that since
mark trumbo back in 2014.
and now they're loaded for van meter
they walked in a run
seven nothing diamondbacks the third
consecutive base on balls for josh van
meter and now the story becomes luke
weaver again now the dieback's just got
him three more runs to work with in the
fifth
hit him with a fastball luke weaver had
retired the first 17 cincinnati batters
and with two outs in the sixth he plunks
bandino the one-two to naquin and he
struck him out swinging
and throw down to sega they don't need
that make one was out for the third out
of the inning and that's it kelly threw
on down but a strikeout ends at 7-4
weaver who's still got the no-hitter
through six lost the perfect game luke
weaver back out there's 79 pitches
through six today the reds don't have a
hit broken back and that's the first
reds base hit
luke weaver loses the no-no
with one out in the seventh you get a
nice round of applause from the fans
here at chase field
[Applause]
luke weaver at the top of his game here
today holding a 7-0 lead
the ground into the overshift van meter
peacock hustles over there that's a four
one put out
here's the o2 pitch and a swing and a
miss and peacock carved up saguaro on
three pitches two outs here on the ninth
roots now right now looking like they
want to get on the plane and head to san
francisco
one more time diamondbacks win it seven
nothing
they blanked the reds on only two hits
luke weaver was absolutely outstanding
[Applause]